foreign
Oregon starting off this hour hi
Michelle how are you
I'm great thanks how are you guys better
than we deserve what's up
all they are credit cards
um
and I just want to know what your
thought would be on it it would be like
almost half the interest that it was
when I first got the the car two years
ago
um and then obviously the interest on
the personal loan is way less than the
credit cards so it makes sense to me
that I wanted your opinion what's the
balance
on the cars 12
000 500 and the credit cards
about nineteen thousand okay
all right and what's your interest rate
on your car
uh currently I think it's at nine
percent about seven I think it's yeah I
want to say it's between seven and nine
I I'm not certain I and and the new rate
if you refinanced would be what uh I
have a quote from uh
Credit Karma for like 4.15
okay I doubt that's gonna happen
in this current environment zero percent
chance yeah
so they're just trying to sneak you in
with oh I think you're about to get paid
I think you're about to get bait and
switched that's that's way below Market
rates okay but let's say you saved four
percent on uh give or take almost say
ten thousand dollars is 400 bucks
mm-hmm
okay what's your household income
about 75 000 after taxes and the
interest rate on your credit cards
average on that about twenty thousand
dollar balance is what
I want to say probably like 24 something
like that probably closer to 20. yeah
probably got some at 18. but um yeah
that's probably about right and then the
interest rate on the um
the offered refinance on that is how
much
9.63 or something like that all right so
uh 10 savings let's call it for round
number on twenty thousand dollars is two
thousand dollars
okay so you have you have thirty
thousand dollars in debt
and this move saves you two thousand
four hundred dollars a year
a year right you are not you do not have
a two thousand four hundred dollar
problem you have a thirty thousand
dollar problem
right I understand that yeah
my thought was
that so I've been with new program for a
couple months and um I've convinced my
husband he does the bills and I've
convinced him to stop putting little
extras here on every single one focus on
the smallest pay it off we've paid off
two cards
um we've got the thousand dollars in the
savings yeah you're making progress I'm
trying yeah and I'm trying I want to
like hurry up and it's kind of hard he
doesn't see
the same way I do
these days
here's the point here's the point if you
save 10 on this which is approximately
what you're saving round numbers
um you have addressed ten percent of the
problem
you still have ninety percent of the
problem to address
so if you want to do it that's fine
but it's laughable that you think you
did something
I just said 90 of the problem is still
not addressed
got it you addressed ten percent of the
problem this is the problem with debt
consolidation
because debt consolidation
intellectually psychologically triggers
your brain and makes you think you did
something
it's like and you did you did do
something but it's only ten percent you
still have 90 of the problem and so we
have to address this on a higher plane
at a different level with a different
approach and if you want to do it that's
fine but I want you guys uh working
extra jobs not seeing inside of a
restaurant unless you work there I want
you saying no more vacations and we're
on a written budget and we're working
together and we're paying off these debt
smallest to largest and we sold so much
stuff the kids think they're next
okay and when you get there now you're
addressing the 90 if you also want to do
the other that's fine but when people do
what you're describing to me they don't
do the other and 88 of the time they end
up with more debt no that's what I don't
want yeah so that's kind of where I'm at
I like you know just keep hammering away
at the credit card so what I would tell
you is this you got 30 000 worth of debt
if you can pay off ten to fifteen
thousand dollars by June 1st without
doing this then if you want to refinance
the balance of it at that point because
you've proven to yourself you're willing
to address the real problem which is you
got it you are the real problem your
husband is the real problem then you can
do this but I'm afraid that you're going
to activate the part of your brain
here's how you know okay the the uh the
Bible says the in the abundance of the
heart the mouth speaks so the way what
we think comes out of our mouth if we're
not real careful okay including on the
show
so here's what you said you said I'm
going to pay off my debt
you're no you're not you're gonna move
you're going to move it yeah you're
borrowing to lower interest which I know
but my point is your heart is feeling
like you did something like I paid it
all right you didn't pay it off you just
moved it around a little bit well and I
know that and that's that's part of the
thing so one of the credit cards that we
owe on that we currently owe on
basically he's not paying anything on it
so that was going to kind of cover that
too because it basically he pays 200 a
month but it's not taking anything off I
pay minimum payments on everything but
your smallest debt attack your smallest
debt with a Vengeance work extra sell
stuff don't go out to eat don't go on
vacation work extra sell stuff don't buy
anything and live on beans and rice rice
and beans where your friends think
you've joined a cult and your
mother-in-law thinks you need counseling
and then what's going to happen is you
can pay off 30 000 making 75 000 in
about 18 months doing that and that's
approximately two thousand dollars a
month
okay and you're a different person on
the back end
right I understand that it's just
getting him do you remember how old are
you how old are you Michelle
I'm 54. do you remember back in the
early 80s when a diet was Tab and like a
neutral light bar and a half of a
grapefruit
yes that's what you're trying to do
right you're trying to shortcut and hack
your way to this don't there's no hack
yeah I mean you're right getting him to
do the whole thing because here's what
happened interest rates did not put you
guys 30 000 in debt your decisions did
interest rates are not keeping you in
debt your decisions are and so again I'm
fine with you doing the refinance the
the debt consolidation it does make
mathematical sense but IT addresses 10
percent of the issue you've got to
address the other 90 or you're not going
to win and I've done you a disservice
unless I preach at you like this because
I love you and I want you to win thanks
for calling